i got it i got the story for you guys
from timcast.com lapd tells residents to
cooperate and comply with robbers
amid rising burglaries there you go i
want you to imagine two
societies one in which everyone for the
most part is armed and unwilling to
comply period
criminals would be like there's no point
in trying to rob this person they'll
scream they'll attack me and my life
will be at risk now i want you to
imagine another society in which uh they
are the government tells everyone do
whatever you're told and you're not
allowed to be armed well now the
criminals know you will do nothing to me
and you can't yeah
that's that's literally like clockwork
orange
where you've got these robbers and and
people are just
comply with them just because they're
they're afraid that the situation will
get worse my mentality has always been
growing up in chicago if anyone comes
near me i will make sure they understand
it will be a very bad day and they might
take my stuff they might win in a fight
against me but i'll tell you this
there's a guy across the street who will
drop to his knees and beg you
i will swing at you so leave me the
alone and you know what
growing up in in chicago with all the
violence and the shootings and
everything i've only been there there
was only one time someone tried mugging
me and i told him to shove off and he
threatened me and i left
plainclothes anti-crime police then
emerged out of the out of nowhere true
story grabbed the guy and screamed in
his face
i could have as soon as the guy walked
up to me just been like just take take
everything from me take take my wallet
my phone you know and i didn't have any
money anyway
but no i just kept walking and i laughed
and i was like you're an idiot i was
like i don't have any money anyway and
he was like yo i got a knife and i was
like oh
i'm just making fun of him and then
if i didn't keep walking
um i don't know if the cops would have
would have seen him and caught him
if i stood there in you know on the
street corner in in it was a dark out
maybe he would have pulled the weapon or
whatever but i ignored him and i said
you ain't getting nothing for me dude
and then i i this is another reason why
i think police are a good thing when
done properly is three cops a plain
clothes officer walked up and grabbed
him and slammed him up against a fence
and screamed not in my town and i was
like whoa apparently he had seen the guy
earlier harassing women and they were
keeping an eye on him so good on the
cops
i just i i think my attitude has always
been be it auntie for anybody if you
want
the path of least resistance to
terrorize someone and rob them it ain't
going to be me yeah well that headline
is what we were saying right before the
show started and you you prefaced at the
beginning of your your of the show um
they use our values against us and our
values are let's not hurt these poor
people they they're robbing for a reason
right we have to understand what their
plight is and let's just comply let's
get along our values of of of
sensibility of society of goodness or
whatever you want to label it christian
or not um they use those values against
us and that is that is the weakest thing
a society could do is to let your values
be turned against you for your own
destruction do you know they did a study
where they took convicted criminals
violent offenders muggers robbers
burglars rapists etc and they showed
them images of people walking
and they said
uh you know rate the likelihood you
would victimize you would target this
person for a mugging and they all did
and they found
the people that were chosen by the
criminals had typically been attacked
before
they found that the way you carry
yourself if you present weakness or just
or you're distracted makes you more
likely to be targeted so if you're
walking upright
shoulders you know
up squared it's till you're squared
head straight up walking firm and
confidently they leave you alone not
even by conscious thought their
subconscious is like this person's going
to be a problem for me well it's like
lions hunting and you know i knew some
criminals in new york city it was like
they could sense someone's weakness they
prayed on people's weakness and i had
different responses uh with the police i
mean there was many times
i got jumped a couple times i knew other
people got jumped a lot of times the
police officers just kind of like rolled
by then it didn't do nothing i'm like
i'm getting the crap beat out of me by
all these people and then and i had a
number of these incidents but imagine
being a police officer i mean being a
criminal
in los angeles right now reading this
this is open season this is great like
yes that's what's happening like do you
see the video uh there's the video from
san francisco where the guy goes in the
walgreens or the garbage bag on a bike
and he's just shoveling stuff in or the
women who go to the makeup section and
they're shoveling it all in or in
connecticut you see this video they go
in the store and they load up three
shopping carts and just walk out with it
and then you hear someone say don't do
it jim you'll you'll get fired what
you tell criminals
that no one will do anything against
them when they commit crimes they're
going to be like okay this is what i
don't get about the san francisco thing
why did they announce it that they
weren't going to be president
they're announcing this this is open
season for average people that can't
defend themselves as of course they have
to jump through hoops to even be able to
have a firearm like this i get because
it's kind of like a public broadcast
they want everyone in la to know but the
the san francisco thing why wouldn't
they just keep it like hey by the way we
are going to prosecute you just so you
know and then just not do it so at least
there was like this yo because they're
on the side of the criminals because
they believe that the path to racial
justice is the destruction of this
country the reparations that's their law
enforcement is thinking that way this is
it's the watchman let me explain
something it's the watchman i need you
need to have destruction in order to be
able to rebuild well so it's it's
actually quite simple
there i remember the old conspiracy
theory about the amero do you guys
remember this yeah luke you remember the
amero right oh yep north american
currency it never happened but the idea
was that
you know canada's got the canadian
dollar the american dollar this is the
mexican peso and they wanted to create a
currency that would work between all
three countries never happened i don't
know if it was called cocaine well it's
called the america right now but here's
the point
what what the conspiracy uh entailed was
that
powerful actors in each government
needed to normalize the economies before
you could implement a single singular
currency if the value of the canadian
dollar is lower than the american dollar
you can't introduce one currency because
it would destroy the canadian economy
what they need to happen is the american
economy to crash to the level of canada
and mexico and once they're normalized
then
you will you will get the opportunity
for a one
one continent currency
what the ideology of the left is is that
there is historical and systemic racism
among black and brown communities but
not asian communities which is why they
don't include them of course so the idea
is if you have a city with a rich white
neighborhood in a poor black
neighborhood and you burn the whole city
to the ground now everyone is at the
same level and let them start again
equally this this is exactly what
they're doing with the great reset which
is really interesting to me too they're
like oh this is total chaos but there's
great opportunity here like okay well
that seems really suspicious at best but
i was going to say too i think this la
thing is going to be a huge red pill for
people on gun control because when you
put gun control into these places
criminals are like hey man i don't care
it's just one more law i'm gonna be
breaking i'm gonna get a hold of a gun
from indiana or whatever lori lightfoot
complains about in chicago and they're
like i'm gonna go through with it this
is basically christmas coming early
because people are unarmed if there's
somebody who's like
got not no moral uh um uh compass
preventing them from killing someone i'm
pretty sure jail is not a deterrent no
no no guy in kenosha and you remember
cooperate and comply it's going to be
easier if you just comply people who who
make those arguments about complying
just oh
i absolutely bothered the crap i i feel
like
if every single person
was an angry
arrogant individual when it came to
these muggings or robberies or whatever
there would be no robberies these
criminals would be like there's a woman
and she would just go
and then pull out a gun
they'd be like i ain't going anywhere
near any of these people are crazy
instead we have a society full of scared
timid victims well that's the problem
with again growing up in new york city
is that guns were illegal and so you
couldn't defend yourself home break-ins
were fairly frequent because they knew
you didn't have a gun my dad used to
have knives above most of the lentils
and most of the doors in the house and i
remember asking about and he's like i
have to defend the house somehow and you
know you can have a gun so if you're a
criminal
what's the most that's going to happen
they're going to come at you with a
steak knife so you break down the doors
and the uh kevin mcallister method is
also illegal yeah unfortunately yeah
booby traps yeah booby trapping your
home is actually you can't do it it's
illegal yeah so right so when that
little kid puts the paint bucket at the
top of the stairs oh you'll go to prison
for that defending yourself in any way
in new york city you go to jail if
someone robs you someone attacks you you
leave a blemish or a mark on them the
police officers put you in jail that's
insane in new jersey people keep telling
me that there is castle doctrine and
they commented all the time and you're
wrong
technically new jersey has castle
doctrine but it's an affirmative defense
meaning if you are in your home
in your in your boxers eating a midnight
burrito when all of a sudden your door
gets kicked in and a guy lit and a group
of people all dressed like the joker
brandishing weapons walk in so you grab
your you know your your ar-15 and you
say oh no they have guns and they're
threatening my life and you shoot them
sure you have castle doctrine but don't
worry the police will be there to arrest
you you'll be charged with homicide in
each incident and then when you go to
trial you can beg the jury to believe
you when you say i had no choice i was
defending myself whereas now that maybe
that may be a circumstance that occurs
in many states but there are many states
where the cops would come in and be like
this person entered your home and they
have a gun
i'm sorry this happened you have a nice
day well that's why the known fact is
that you make sure you drag the body in
as far into the living room as possible
i mean i remember a couple tell me that
in new york city if you ever have to
kill someone who breaks into your house
after you stab them in the doorway drag
them as far into the house as possible
yeah states blue stuff literally don't
touch them but
in new york in new jersey in illinois if
someone breaks into your home and
threatens your life to your face you
defend yourself you will be charged and
it's because of those policies
in in washington dc which is just as bad
as new york or anywhere else
that those who can't afford to cross the
river and they move into arlington and
they move into alexandria and they move
into fairfax but then they vote exactly
the same way they did as they were just
in in and then like virginia is a blue
state no it's not it's as red as red
could be but it's got this really
intense very small blue dot and it's
51 of the population as the politicians
who implement this policy go behind
their gated communities and live in the
protected society it's just
mind-boggling to see this repeat over
and over again and i think truly people
have the ability to arm themselves to
defend themselves the situation would be
so much different so much better for the
rest of society because you level the
playing field people need to understand
when you're in a place that bans guns
innocent people can't defend themselves
criminals can have guns and will have
guns because they're criminals they
don't care about the law or they don't
care about gun-free zones they will have
weakness you won't as long as it's
muskets though because that's what the
second amendment's about it's about
musketeers we are very close there could
be a supreme court ruling which grants
nationwide constitutional carry
effectively we'll see basically the the
issue is that new york is a may issue
state you apply for a concealed carry
and they say well think about it you
need a valid reason it's almost
impossible to get new jersey is also a
may issue state however effectively
they're known as a no issue state
because in new jersey you can say
someone threatened my life i need a gun
for personal protection and they'll say
thank you for your attempt at getting a
weapon now get out you're never getting
one so the supreme court's going to hear
this case i believe it's pertaining to
the new york lawsuit where it would
require states to issue concealed carry
in a reasonable amount of time for any
reason because we have a second
amendment thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you